aujourd'hui que 3800 merci monsieur le
ministre la parole est à monsieur
dominique tian merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre monsieur prix ministres
où vous venez de remercier une ministre
loyal qui avait mis finalement place
votre réforme territoriale très
contestée d'ailleurs manable lebranchu
vous nommer à sa place au sixième rang
protocolaire devant le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur baylet qui est
certes très expérimenté mais fille qui
fut aussi un adversaire résolu de votre
réforme territoriale ainsi je rappelle
dans un communiqué du 24 juin 2014
monsieur baylet s'opposer à la nouvelle
carte des régions une réforme disait-il
menés à marche forcée et au mépris et au
mépris des réalités géographiques
historiques et sociologiques pire
monsieur wiley devra composer avec
grelier ce qu'eta d'état à la réforme
territoriale qui est sonos qui taisent
parfaite et qu'elle est même époque
applaudissez dès demain la suppression
des départements
alors que monsieur baylet président du
parti radical de gauche menaçait de
retirer ses ministres radicaux du
gouvernement pour les raisons inverses
je pourrais me permettre de dire que ça
pourrait apparaître comme l'alliance de
la carpe et du lapin
monsieur le premier ministre à l'époque
où les collectivités territoriales
connaissent une situation financière
dramatique à la suite des baisses de
dotations de l'état de 50 milliards
d'euros à la suite des difficultés
d'application de la loi notre loi mal
rédigée et qui met des collectivités
dans situations invraisemblables
monsieur le premier ministre pourriez
vous nous expliquer la cohérence de
votre choix
la parole est à monsieur jean michel
bailly les ministres de l'aménagement
des territoires de la ruralité sur le
président vctv terme peser sur le député
monsieur le député une fois n'est pas
coutume ce député vous remercier du
thème polémique de votre question
pourtant j'ai plutôt le goût pour le
consensus
mais cela va me permettre d'entrée de
jeu d'entrée de jeu de clarifier un
certain nombre de choses par rapport aux
responsabilités ministérielles qui ont
été confiées tant estelle grelier
qu'armand même parle prend la république
et le premier ministre se le député dans
l'action publique il ya le temps de la
réflexion
est-il utile de mener telle ou telle loi
allait aller oui ou non
enel dont l'enfant section il ya le
temps de la concertation c'est le débat
et dans ce cadre là effectivement avec
estelle grelier ses élus et ses
habilités et les mandats qui étaient les
nôtres nous ont fait connaître nos
positions ça s'appelle tout simplement
la démocratie et la diversité d'opinion
vous n'allez pas en vert à avoir à
droite de diversité d'opinion surtout
quand on est cadre du cours d'ailleurs
pour l'élan figé tranquille manche est
plein et on roule un peu calmé monsieur
le député vient le temps de la décision
c'est le vote de la loi par le parlement
et qu'un la loi est votée sur le
territoire de la république
elle s'applique à tous un langage tout
le monde a fortiori les membres du
gouvernement alors monsieur le député si
vous le souhaitez nous pouvons dans ce
sens travailler ensemble comme nous
l'avons fait ce matin excellemment avec
l'ensemble des élus corses dans leur
diversité et parfois valeur vis
divergences de manière sérieuse et de
manière utile pour arriver à porter un
avenir le meilleur possible pour ce
magnifique territoire
si vous si vous êtes dans cette manière
républicaine et démocratique durant les
chaudes
je vous engage à venir travailler avec
nous sur la sur l'avenir des
collectivités dans l'intérêt des élus et
de nos concitoyens
merci